تقرير جديد يزعم أن
حرس الحدود السعوديين قتلوا
مئات المهاجرين الذين كانوا يحاولون عبور
الحدود من اليمن تقول هيومن رايتس ووتش إنهم أجروا
مقابلات مع عشرات
المهاجرين وقاموا بتحليل مئات الصور
ومقاطع الفيديو للعثور على أدلة على
القتلى والجرحى  استمع
الآن إلى أحد الأشخاص الذين أجريت معهم مقابلات وما
أخبروه المنظمة عن
الهجوم، استمع إلى أنهم
كانوا يطلقون النار بدون توقف واعتقدت أن
السماء كانت تسقط علي، اعتقدت أنني
كنت أحلم في البداية، لم أصدق
عيني  نظرت حولي وسقطت
عيني عليها مرة أخرى، علمت أنه لم تعد لدي ساق،
وبدأت أصلي مستلقيًا هناك،
زملائي الإثيوبيين يخططون للذهاب إلى
السعودية، من فضلك انظر إلي، هناك مطر
من الرصاص في انتظارك، انظر إلي
وتعلم
ذلك الرد على  التقرير
قال مصدر حكومي سعودي لـCNN إن
المزاعم وتقرير هيومن رايتس ووتش
بشأن إطلاق حرس الحدود السعوديين النار على
إثيوبيين أثناء
عبورهم الحدود السعودية اليمنية لا أساس لها من الصحة
ولا تستند إلى
مصادر موثوقة الآن، وتأتي هذه الاتهامات في
وقت تشعر فيه المملكة  القيام
باستثمارات دولية ضخمة في مجموعة متنوعة
من الشركات في جميع أنحاء العالم،
بما في ذلك الرياضات رفيعة المستوى مثل
الجولف وكرة القدم، والآن يعتقد الكثيرون أن هذه الإجراءات
جزء من حملة لغسل
البلاد أو تطهيرها من سمعتها
المشكوك فيها في مجال حقوق الإنسان. انضم
إلي الآن  على كل هذا، سارة لي
ويتسون هي رئيسة الديمقراطية في
العالم العربي الآن
الآن المنظمة التي لديكم الآن
تسمى الفجر وقد أنشأها
جمال خاشقجي وهو صحفي سعودي
تم قتله وتقطيعه بالطبع
داخل القنصلية السعودية
في تركيا عام 2018. مرحبًا بسارة لي ويلسون
في البرنامج، كما تعلمون،
الادعاءات ليست أقل من
مذهلة أن حرس الحدود السعوديين أطلقوا النار
حرفيًا بدم بارد على المهاجرين
واللاجئين من مسافة قريبة مع أشخاص
قُتلوا وعُذبوا
وجنسيًا  أريد أن أؤكد أن
CNN لا يمكنها التحقق بشكل مستقل من هذه
الحوادث ولكن ما هو رد فعلك؟
رد فعلي بالطبع هو الصدمة
والرعب لأنه بينما كنا
نوثق الانتهاكات على الحدود السعودية
لسنوات عديدة أه المتعلقة بإساءة معاملة
المهاجرين،
هذا التقرير الجديد يوثق
قُتل مئات المهاجرين على مدى ثلاثة أشهر
وتعرضوا لأشد
الانتهاكات المروعة سادية مثل
إجبار مهاجر على اغتصاب
مهاجر آخر أو مواجهة الموت عندما
رفض سؤال المهاجرين عن الطرف الذي
يريدون إطلاق النار عليه بسبب إلقاء
متفجرات كبيرة في
تقتل مخيمات المهاجرين النساء والأطفال
بأجزاء من أجسادهم في كل مكان، إنه
مستوى صادم حقًا من الفساد، لقد
تم توثيق ذلك وهو ما
يصدمك كما تقول الآن، أريد
أن أكرر، لا تستطيع CNN التحقق بشكل مستقل من
هذه الحوادث في
الحكومة السعودية، وقال مصدر لـ CNN I  سوف
نكرر ما يقولونه بأن
الادعاءات الواردة في هيومن رايتس
ووتش لا أساس لها من الصحة ولا تستند إلى
مصادر موثوقة. هل يمكنك أن تشرح
لمشاهدينا أنك مدير سابق لـ هيومن رايتس
ووتش في المنطقة، كيف يتم
فحص هذه التقارير والبحث فيها
بشكل جيد؟  تحقيقات مفصلة جداً
مع شهود عيان أه
الضحايا الأطباء نحن عادة نراجع
السجلات الطبية نراجع
البقايا المادية للمتفجرات طلقات الأسلحة
هذا التقرير بالذات استخدم
صور الأقمار الصناعية والصور المتوفرة على
نطاق واسع لتوثيق مواقع الدفن أه
صور تظهر الجثث المقطعة
أه أه الجثث المنهوبة ثم طبعا
المهاجرين والشهود
أنفسهم يصفون ما حدث،
هذه التقارير مدعمة بشكل وثيق جدًا
ومدمجة داخليًا
مع عملية مراجعة صارمة للغاية وبالنسبة للإنكار
السعودي أه يجب أن أقول إنني
لم أر تحقيقًا واحدًا في مجال حقوق الإنسان
يوثق الأدلة
التي تثبت أنهم لم يفعلوا ذلك  "إن الرفض العرضي
والرفض غير صحيح، لقد
كانوا يفعلون ذلك على مدار السنوات السبع الماضية
فيما يتعلق
بالقصف العشوائي لليمنيين الذي أودى
بحياة 370 ألف شخص والرد القياسي
أه من
حكومة المملكة العربية السعودية هو فقط  مجرد الإنكار
والتظاهر بأن شيئًا لم يحدث